Here's a look at what we'll be covering in this course.
We'll start with an introduction,
where I will try to sell you on the joy of data plumbing,
one of my very favorite topics.
We'll go through some main tools.
These are what I like to think of as the Power BI sandwich,
where you have Power Query,
where you load the data,
you've got the data modeling layer where you make relationships.
Then of course there's a reporting layer on top,
where you make all the beautiful visualizations that you know and love.
We'll get into a little bit greater depth with
that Power BI data pipeline from soup to nuts,
where we'll talk about how those different pieces come together and align.
Then we'll go into key concepts.
This is really where we get into the designing and structuring of a data model,
which is an important prerequisite before you
get into the technology and start moving things around.
We'll start with data model components,
which will be fact tables,
dimension tables, relationships, and keys.
Different pieces that you're going to need to connect
together so that your data will perform the way you want it to.
We'll talk about the hows and whys of data modeling and transforming the data,
so you'll have a better sense before we jump into using Power BI and Power Query,
what we're trying to accomplish and what the underlying goals are,
that we'll be using this technology to make happen.
Then we'll take our first step in using Power Query.
We'll be getting data and we'll explore
not only the Power Query basics of how you use power Query to pull in information,
but also all the different options that you have when it comes to Power Query.
You'll find that there's a lot of different ways that you can access data.
We'll also go through Common Data transformations.
Once you have that data pulled into Power Query from various sources,
how do you make it organized and
structured in a way that will align with Power Queries needs,
so you can understand what the data is and so that you can
understand where to find it and what each of
those things are when you pull it into the data model layer.
Finally, we'll talk about data types.
This is a really important concept because it
impacts everything from how filters are applied,
to how the data is able to be presented at the reporting level.
Next, we'll get into bigger transformations.
I have to say this is my favorite lesson.
It's where we really get to put our wizard hats on and
do some really magical things with the data.
We'll start with addressing errors and gaps in the data.
This is the cleaning of data that often needs to happen to make sure
that information aligns exactly with how the report needs to work,
while also taking care to ensure that the potential corrections that you make
aren't over-cleaning the data or causing
the information to be misleading at the reporting layer.
Then we'll talk about transformations across queries.
This is where beyond just the basics of structuring your data,
you can mush the data together,
or what I like to think of as stapling it from
one to the other so that everything is aligned the way you need it to.
You can also do cool things like unpivoting
the data and organizing your data in new ways,
splitting the data so that you have it the way that you need it.
What I like to think of as transfiguration.
We'll talk about creating date tables as well.
Then we'll go into creating date tables.
You'll find as we go through this process,
that date tables are a really important part
of the overall data model that you'll be building.
Specifically because this enables things like time intelligence to be used,
and to ensure that the date structure
that's used within your table aligns with your needs.
Next, we'll go into relationships and DAX.
Relationships are a really important part of the overall data model.
I like to think of them as creating the sinew of the data model.
The filters determine which direction that
the relationships carry key information related to the dimensions.
We'll talk about how DAX uses those relationships.
DAX is data analytics expressions,
and it's important calculations that we'll use within our reports and data models.
Then we'll get into reporting and even more DAX in our final lesson.
This will include other schemas,
situations where a standard star schema
doesn't really work the way that we would need it to.
For example, when we have more than one fact table,
or we need to include more than one date table,
or even a disconnected table to allow for
parameters and additional reporting considerations.
We'll talk about basic reporting on that final reporting layer.
We'll include tables, but also matrices.
We'll have cards, and we'll include a little bit about how to use
textboxes to enable you to add additional information to your report.
We'll talk about common DAX for reports,
building on the prior lesson.
These are things like if and switch
statements that you can use to add some nuance and depth to your reporting.
Finally, we'll go through troubleshooting for every layer of the Power BI sandwich.
This will allow us to ensure that you have tidied up information
as well as the most efficient data model and report possible,
based on everything that we've learned so far in this course.